I'm gonna just call her hold on oh my
god I can't get to my mom because there
are so many messages mom
we're on Entertainment Tonight
hold on mom you're on speakerphone
we're on Entertainment Tonight I'm
calling you yes right now and I'm
calling you I love you mom
okay all right Cheers people who know me
I'm southern raised I dedicated this you
know to my mom and dad who know New
Orleans tonight they're still with us
which is wow that's amazing hold on I
want to hear you okay my mom and dad are
still with us which is remarkable and I
I'm lucky I had a beautiful childhood
but I play very damaged people but I
think I'm capable of that realize I had
the real because I had I had the
childhood to to handle the the trauma I
I know what it is I I know what it is to
have it and so to not have it I play
many people who didn't have the
childhood I had sharp objects really
takes you on a weird wild journey if
you're not ready for it
what was it like reading the script and
how did you know that was the role you
were like this is right well I spoke to
the magnificent and perfect Gillian
Flynn and Marti Noxon Gillian wrote it
Marti Noxon Gillian wrote conceived this
it's based on a book and these were two
powerhouse women and you know when you
talk to two powerhouse women yeah do you
ever say no no never you have no choice
okay okay okay
no they had me out of hello you
mentioned that at 59 there aren't these
roles that are out there and they're
offered but
the talent is there and it's so good so
what does it mean now to get a role like
this at 50 nothing I was 57 when I got
it but yeah what was it say to actresses
in the city the world just we first of
all everything is shifting in our
industry everything yes everything and
it is what we need it is women are
moving in a the direction that they
should have been for years but we
finally haven't known and we've arrived
in a way we've never been present in
this endeavor and times I we are
standing on the shoulders of all those
women who spoke up spoke out I'm
thankful thank you okay you hear your
name called what goes through your head
when you hear your name called what is
that moment HBO table and I owe
everything to HBO I love them I did six
feet under with them I'm back here which
was this is late I know and I have two
Emmys and now I have a Golden Globe like
I don't know I'm gonna build a shrine to
HBO what do you think when you hear your
name oh I thought okay
remember remember the people you want to
think and I just with my big long dress
on all this tool I thought okay nobody
stepped on my dress and remember the
people I need to think wow okay before
you go last thing
Amy how great was it well I said I owe
you so very much
I owe her absolutely what you told her
yes I said I owe you so much she wanted
me for this character
I'm here because of her and we will be
celebrating later did it take a minute
to get this character out of your brain
yes was it hard wasn't it but Amy helped
Amy and I both I mean we had to
transition but she's extraordinary and
she's one of the greatest actresses I've
ever met and worked with ever ever ever
ever
congratulations taking all minute
[Music]